The Joe Rogan experience. Joe, you did it.
You might be right about this racist shit,
by the way,
because the only other ones that
don't have to pay taxes. The, the,
the golf league. The PGA and that. The NHL
Peter [inaudible].
Hold on. There's another fellow. Well Dad
is fucking creepy. You should be pissed.
Yeah. Doug Golf guys don't have to
pay tax like the most money. Right?
Wow. That's dark. That's dark,
dark racism. Wow. I think it's racism.
I'm crying racism for the NBA and
I don't even watch basketball.
Yeah. The idea that you could get
away with that Scientology thing,
that that could be,
we need to start our own fucking religion.
That's what needed to do.
God dammit.
That's how you're really
good tip blockchains.
That's how you're really locked down.
That's the quote right there.
When this dog and
religion, God dammit. Well,
they have so much money that
they can get away with it.
Like Scientology is a number
to land owner in Los Angeles.
They own more buildings and
property real estate in Los Angeles.
Then like almost anybody,
hey freakiest thing is,
you know how to rope off everything
at a time square when, uh,
when the ball is going to
drop or whatever. Yeah.
And there's a certain time you
can't go past the barricades.
One night I was there and the guy said,
why are you a member of the Church
of Scientology? And I said, yeah.
And he let me in through the barricade.
Real Story. Dude. Real Story.
He probably just wanted to fuck you.
[inaudible] handsome guy.
[inaudible]
take a cod podcast.
[inaudible] press a button.
You gotta keep the ball moving. What is
the, wow, what are you supposed to say?
Amazing.
He probably loved you,
dude. The Scientologists friends I could
give me goosebumps are really good song.
Didn't give me goosebumps.
Like the other day I was driving
home and radar love came on.
You know that song you've
ever heard that song? Oh God.
It's like a one hit wonder band from
the sixties or seventies pull that,
pull that out. Brian is the
greatest driving music of all time.
And when I was 18 years old,
I had this girlfriend that
moved to western Massachusetts.
I was living in Boston,
I was living in Newton and she moved to
like an hour and a half away and he's to
have to drive to go visit her.
And My cars were always pieces of shit,
so it's always a death drive.
Then one time I broke down in the
snow storm halfway to visitors.
Fucking huge disaster.
But uh,
I had a cassette and I would play this
song radar love because it's all about
driving.
It's all about driving when
you're exhausted and just
keeping your foot on the
gas.
And this song came on the other day and
my whole body tangled like I'm driving
and I heard it come on,
like as I change the channel,
it was right with a drum starts beating
right here,
right here.
And that's right when I hit the channel
and that was in the car and I was
driving and it was late at
night. Any, first of all,
my whole body started tingling and it
brought me immediately back the beans,
some half retarded,
18 year old driving my piece of shit.
Audi Fox that could fall
apart at any minute.
Wheels could fly off and go
in the fucking oncoming lanes.
Listen to this shit though.
Their boys in my head that Mikey d
some dude did this to
it's half as as I'm shifting
[inaudible]
red.
That's a powerful fucking song.
They have loved radar love.
She sends it out and he gets in the
car and fucking guns it over there.
That's fucking beautiful. Thank you for
introducing that to me. It's tingly.
It gives me tingles.
So tell me man we were,
we were talking about this but
we got off track, up subject.
What did you do the entire
year that you were in? Solid.
Sorry,
what was your day?
Did all to wake up cause
cause it was weird.
They would feed us like at m
4:00 AM was breakfast, right?
Does that wake you have a
feed you breakfast and eat
and pass back out. Right.
And then you get up again,
like really nine or 10 and hour
and 10 o'clock we'll be lunch.
That's what need you to
tell it. [inaudible] weird
schedule, pick the lunch.
And then from that point
on I will just read,
I would read from 10:00 AM until like 11
at night and I'll take an hour break to
work out.
Wow.
I mean I read the second year I
kept track of with 117 books. Wow.
But um, I, there's not any way
I could ever have way more.
But you went out of books, you know,
you run out of books. It's so boring.
I only came out of my cell every other
day for an hour, you know what I mean?
And then just like a
just fucking board dude.
What is it like to not talk to people
for so long? I mean you talked to,
I mean it's just weird dude.
It's like a, as far as anybody,
it's like a fucking time warp
because when you're in there,
the day goes by real slow with like the
months go by quick and then when you get
out it's just like, it's like a, it
was all a dream. You didn't move.
You weren't even in there. It's weird.
It fucks with your head and then like,
oh it was whoa man, they under fed us so
bad. Do they fucking on the Fed is bad.
Yeah. And last thing real bad, uh, I was
trying to calculate how much protein,
I thought that was good in a day and it
was like 20, 30 grams, dude, Whoa, here's,
here's, I know it was
bullshit. And this is in Vegas,
especially if it's anything
goes better in Vegas.
We only got a piece of
fruit like twice a week.
So like we've got like an orange like
twice or three times a week. That's it.
But it's weird cause Mayweather was there,
right? So may when I got there to his,
his like two months sends fucking,
he started bitching at the, at the,
at the judge like they're not feeding
me enough to give me shit for you,
blah blah blah.
All of a sudden Bam fruit every day.
Big Portions, all this shit for all of
you. Everyone. Right. Cause I know why.
I know why.
Because they were scared that maybe
whether it's camp was going to have the,
the people that feed us, you
know, investigating. Yeah.
You know, and guess what,
the second he left went away. Wow. No
Shit. I swear to God. And I told the,
I told one of the cool, God's aim and
come here. I say notice motherfucker.
They as soon as me with her
started bitching at court,
now we've got bigger trades and we got
fruit everyday and he started chuckling
and he laughed and walked
away. Blight. It's like they
knew, they knew what was up.
They were undefeated
on the fuck out of us.
Yeah. My Brother Sam is the cherries
and the brother wrote it. Yeah. Big,
big part of it that keeps sticking with
me was that he was like this really
normal quiet kind of kid and
then he got hit in the head.
He got like hit by a car and he got
really fucked up and when he recovered he
became this reckless fucking maniac.
He became Kennison. So you know,
a big part of what made him so
amazing might've been an accident.
Like that happens sometimes.
Like there was a story recently
about a guy who got hit in the head.
He had some sort of head injury and
then he came out of it and he could play
music. Like there's weird things
that happen sometimes, right?
I went to school with a girl that had
a head injury in that she got huge tits
and I'm not trying to be funny.
I wish I was lying to you.
This chick was flat chested is fuck.
Got a head injury her freshman year.
By the time she was a junior,
her tits were fucking ginormous and
should become like this sex fucking crazy
chick like,
and I went to grammar school with her.
I knew she wasn't a sex fiend and I
bumped into like when she was a senior and
she was fucking nuts. I was
a junior. I was like, Jesus,
just to fucking kids and just wondering
to fuck. Just, just, you know,
like if this guy doesn't fuck me,
y'all gonna fuck me. I'm like, ah.
I don't think I had injury. Think it
was, now that you said that, well,
think about Shannon and reusable and now
she won't talk to me now. She made up, I,
my buddy of mine bumped
into her and she goes,
I don't talk for that mother fucker.
She wasn't talking about slow because
she wasn't, you wouldn't bug her.
I don't know what it was. And I,
and I still mad in the freshman.
That's the girl I got left back
over. Oh Wow. In the seventh grade,
from meeting her pussy and shit like that,
she wouldn't let me bang.
I just dry humped and suck the
titties and stuff like that.
[inaudible].